thank you alejandro yes i'm here with uh
wesley so the current leader
of uh super bad chess classic wesley
five rounds have passed how do you feel
uh after
halfway through yeah i feel good i mean
first i'd like to apologize for
quicker i mean no one likes a quick
throw but you were black in this one
yeah that's true and uh i was
playing bogdan who's a very talented 19
year old i think he's
he's very focused on chess right now he
got the in
he got the invitation last minute for
the grand chester by still playing
extremely well i think
in in this tournament so he has a bright
future ahead of him i think he's very
focused on chess as i said and also if
he continues working hard and gets the
right invitation and support i think
he'll he'll go far
obviously the pandemic things have
changed but yeah you chose uh the vienna
and you don't usually play this uh what
was
your strategy going into this game yeah
that's true yeah i
chose the bien i mean i thought he would
play the catalan because he played
catalan twice in this event so i thought
he would stick to it but i played
knight c3 and the thing is like i
prepared this bishop b4 line against
alexander christchurch
a few couple days ago and
since i did a lot of work on it i
figured i might as well
use it for today while my memory is
still fresh
but obviously it's not the best opening
by far
by all means and the problem also
after it takes this one sacrifice
uh it's very risky for black objectively
white has many different ways to push
and white is not really
worse even with a pawn down and so this
line basically
give offers black zero winning chances
but
i thought i'm i wasn't sure if he was
gonna play the knight c3 line
and i thought since i already analyzed
it even if it's a bad line might as well
play it and yeah problem i mean it's all
theory
i mean why does other moves of course on
move nine that
put some pressure but this has all been
played before i mean
here white can retreat through three
different ways and then black replies
three different
ways and here he got player e5 of course
mob 17 and white is not really risking
anything
despite being down upon
but after takes takes the end game is
just pretty it's just
i think completely drawing by force but
yeah again i think i didn't choose the
best opening for today but at the same
time i already studied it so i thought
i might as well play it i mean if you
have to play for win with black
uh then you obviously don't choose queen
scout my decline but maybe you choose
like semi-slab or
or king's indian or or the benoni did
you consider playing for a win with
black uh
or that was a bit too much yeah i mean
my goal in this tournament is to play
some good chess
because some players did against bogdan
and were punished because of it
almost got punished and uh
who did he beat he beat
he
well i mean of course i want to play for
win but not just against bogdan but
bogan is a very good player and very
talented at the same time i go on this
tournament
to play some good chess and sometimes
good chef
leaves to draw us but yeah this this
line with bishop e7 simply doesn't offer
black
any winning chances but it's not like i
made any mistakes or blasters either
and i wasn't sure if bogdan was gonna
press hard today i mean he had some
some options but obviously i had never
played this time with black before and
if you're not
prepared i think he was also a bit
surprised by your opening choice
yeah he was a vienna yeah i mean i was
surprised to play i sit there but
yeah of course i've never played the
vienna before and
i mean this line also if you're not
prepared with white you could
you it's very hard to fight for an
advantage as well wesley what are you
going to do uh to do during the free
day well free day is uh
rest i'm not sure if the organizer has
anything planned for us tomorrow
but i rest days should be
used for for f not as much preparation
but to clear
to clear your brain to clear the
player's brain and to
start the second half of the tournament
they're fresh and ready to fight again
there you go ready to fight again wesley
saw after the rest day
probably going into the rest day as the
leader guys back to you